* Klingelton *
Hier ist Karin.
Hoi.
Du hast einen Auftrag für mich?
Irgendwo im Kanton Zürich
wurde ein Verbrechen begangen.
Karin Bolliger rückt aus.
Ihr Auftrag: vor Ort Spuren sichern.
Während der Anfahrt hat man Zeit,
sich auf den Tatort vorzubereiten.
Man macht sich Gedanken,
was einen erwarten könnte.
Zu intensiv darf man sich
mental aber nicht vorbereiten,
denn es könnte total anders sein.
Die Anspannung lässt meist nach,
wenn man am Tatort ist,
sich mit allen unterhält,
die Leute sieht.
Ja.
* Mysteriöse, unheilvolle Musik *
Unsere erste Herausforderung
an diesem Nachmittag:
aus der Stadt Zürich herauszukommen.
Habt ihr kein Blaulicht,
wenn es ganz schnell gehen muss?
Doch, haben wir.
Es ist hinter mir befestigt.
Wir setzen es aufs Dach
und fahren los.
Aber es sind meist Aufträge,
da wird uns befohlen, mit Blaulicht
zu fahren, wenn es eilt.
Der Brand ist jetzt gelöscht.
Also eilt es nicht mehr.
Nein, die Lage ist unter Kontrolle.
Es geht nun um die Spurensicherung.
Die Kantonspolizei Zürich hat dieses
Auto bereits vom Tatort entfernt
und in eine Garage gebracht,
wo es repariert werden soll,
sobald die Kriminaltechnikerin
ihre Arbeit abgeschlossen hat.
Wozu fotografieren Sie das?
Das sind die üblichen
Übersichtsaufnamen des Tatorts,
von der angetroffenen Situation.
Anhand der Fotos
kann man sich erinnern und schauen,
wie es vorher ausgesehen hat.
Wenn dann über eine gewisse Spur
diskutiert wird, kann ich sagen,
ob diese Spur von mir stammt oder
ob sie schon vorher vorhanden war.
Fotos sind immer sehr, sehr wichtig.
Es kann auch passieren,
dass man auf einem Foto etwas sieht,
das man vorher am Tatort
nicht bemerkt hatte.
Karin Bolliger hält ihre Eindrücke
nicht nur fotografisch,
sondern immer auch schriftlich fest.
Und dann kommt auch noch
ein Wattestäbchen zum Einsatz.
Damit können
DNA-Spuren gesichert werden.
Es ist wirklich schwierig,
denn diejenigen,
die das Auto sichergestellt haben,
haben es schon angefasst.
Die wichtigen Spuren
liegen eigentlich unter dem Russ.
Und auf dem Russ
sind bereits Spuren.
Es ist eindeutig,
dass es schon angefasst wurde.
Jetzt gehen wir zum Brandort -
dorthin,
wo der Brand stattgefunden hat.
Meine Kollegen haben noch andere
mögliche Spuren gefunden
im Zusammenhang mit dieser
Sachbeschädigung durch den Brand.
* Düstere Klänge *
Ja, also.
Eigentlich ist es nicht gut gemacht.
- Ja, wir machen, was wir können.
Mhm.
Aufgrund der Gesamtsituation ...
Heute Morgen war Simone da,
wegen des Spiegels.
Also, eben ...
Wir haben noch ein Stück
des Scheibenwischers
des zweiten Autos gefunden.
Man sieht: Er ist unter dem Auto
und ein wenig geschützt.
Hier könnte man jetzt noch schauen,
ob man irgendwelche Spuren findet,
ob wir was sichern können,
das ein Ergebnis liefert.
Ich schaue mich noch etwas um.
Vielleicht fällt mir etwas auf,
das noch niemandem aufgefallen ist.
Es ist immer besser,
wenn mehrere Augen schauen.
Gibt es auch Tatorte,
die emotional belastend sind?
Sehr viele eigentlich.
Fast alle Tatorte,
die ich untersuche,
sind emotional belastend,
denn dahinter steht immer
ein Schicksal von Menschen.
Die einen
verursachen diese Situation,
die anderen müssen darunter leiden
bzw. sind davon betroffen.
Noch ist unklar,
ob der Brand in dieser Tiefgarage
mit Absicht gelegt wurde.
Die Ermittlungen werden zeigen,
ob hier wirklich
ein Verbrechen vorliegt.
Das ist auch irgendwo abgeschmolzen.
Es ist etwas undefinierbar.
Es ist auch stark bedeckt mit Russ.
Bei so starken Anhaftungen
ist es schwierig,
an DNA-Spuren zu kommen.
Denn der Prozess,
um die DNA herauszufiltern,
gestaltet sich bei so vielen
Russpartikeln sehr schwierig.
Aber eben: Manchmal
muss man es einfach versuchen.
Bolliger macht sich auf den Rückweg
ins Forensische Institut.
Mit dem Sichern der Spuren
ist ihre Arbeit an diesem Fall
noch lange nicht abgeschlossen.
Jetzt sind wir wieder zu Hause.
* Sie lacht leise. *
Sind Sie mit dem Einsatz zufrieden?
Grundsätzlich schon, ja.
Ich denke,
wir haben unser Bestes getan.
Wir haben auch das getan, wovon
wir uns am meisten versprechen.
Nun beginnt die Büroarbeit:
Beweisstücke
werden elektronisch erfasst,
Protokolle und Berichte geschrieben.
Eine Katze sei als Kind
ihr erstes Haustier gewesen,
erinnert sich Bolliger.
Mehr war in einer Wohnung
nicht möglich.
Heute besitzen sie und ihr Mann
ein Haus mit grossem Umschwung
im Rafzerfeld
und halten u.a. zwei Alpakas.
Eine kleine heile Welt.
Sie leben hier sehr idyllisch.
Ist das ein Ausgleich zu Ihrer Arbeit
oder hat das nichts damit zu tun?
Es hat schon sehr viel damit zu tun.
Wenn man über die Brücke
über den Rhein fährt,
fühlt man sich wie in den Ferien,
ein Feriengefühl kommt auf.
Man ist entspannt und ...
Man kann den Alltag abstreifen
und ...
Es ist einfach schön.
Es ist ein Privileg,
so zu leben und zu wohnen.
Tiere und Natur gehen ins Herz,
tun einem einfach gut.
Erholungsphasen seien wichtig
in ihrem Job, sagt sie,
nicht nur physisch, sondern auch im
Kopf weit weg zu sein von Tatorten.
Ihre Freizeit
verbringt sie gerne mit ihrem Mann,
den sie kennenlernte,
lange bevor sie zur Polizei ging.
Sie ist gelernte Pharmaassistentin
und arbeitete später
als Flight-Attendant.
Eigentlich war das wie bei
vielen anderen ein Jugendtraum.
Das ist wirklich so.
Allerdings machte ich dazwischen
noch andere Sachen.
Erst mit 30 ging ich zur Polizei.
Aber ich habe mich immer gefragt,
wie es wäre.
Irgendwann merkte ich,
dass der Zeitpunkt gekommen ist,
mich an die Aufnahmeprüfungen
zu wagen.
Nachdem alles geklappt hatte,
begann ich mit der Polizeischule.
Und heute bin ich immer noch da -
es war die richtige Entscheidung.
Ihr Mann findet,
sie sei eine Idealbesetzung.
Ihre Fähigkeiten
sind auch menschlicher Natur.
Sie spürt, in welcher Verfassung
andere Menschen sind.
Sie hat Sozialkompetenz -
das braucht es bei der Polizei.
Und auch eine gewisse ...
Sie kann in bestimmten Situationen
auch pragmatisch, schnell
und fokussiert handeln.
Ich sah sie von Anfang an
in diesem Beruf,
merkte sofort,
dass sie das gut kann.
Mich interessierten
die Geschichten dahinter.
Ich wollte immer wissen,
was noch dahintersteckt.
Ähm ...
Ich denke, dass man das ...
Entweder man hat es,
oder man hat es nicht.
Es ist natürlich
kein Beruf für jedermann.
Man muss eine gewisse
Grundvoraussetzung mitbringen.
Sie steht morgens um 4 Uhr
motiviert auf, um arbeiten zu gehen.
Das ist irgendwie ...
Es gibt wohl nicht viel Leute,
bei denen das der Fall wäre.
Nachdem sie
Kantonspolizistin geworden war,
wechselte Bolliger
ans Forensische Institut,
das die Kantons- und die Stadtpolizei
Zürich zusammen betreiben.
Seither liefert sie zentrale Puzzle-
teile zur Lösung von Verbrechen.
Für mich ist es irgendwie ...
Ich darf Teil des Ganzen sein,
darf einen wichtigen Beitrag
dazu leisten,
dass Recht durchgesetzt
und Unrecht geahndet werden kann.
Wenn man z.B. zu einem Fingerabdruck
oder einer DNA-Spur
plötzlich den Namen einer Person
hat, die für die Tat infrage kommt,
dann weiss man,
dass es irgendwo weitergeht,
dass man einen Erfolg
verbuchen konnte.
Was damit dann weiter geschieht,
ob die Person
wirklich der Täter ist oder nicht -
das ist ja noch nicht sicher,
wenn man eine Spur hat -,
wie es mit dem Fall weitergeht,
ob es einen Schuldspruch gibt,
das bekommen wir
in der Regel nicht mit.
Würde Sie das interessieren?
In einzelnen Fällen schon.
Aber wenn ich immer nachforschen
oder nachfragen würde,
was in einem Fall passiert ist ...
Wir haben gar nicht die Zeit,
um aus Neugierde zu verfolgen,
was aus einem Fall geworden ist.
Hoi.
Unbekannte
sind in eine Bijouterie eingebrochen.
Bolliger war am Tatort.
Ich eröffne einen Fall
aus meiner letzten Nachtschicht.
Ich gebe alle gesicherten Spuren
ins System ein.
Ähm .. genau.
Ich dokumentiere,
welche Spuren ich gesichert habe,
damit das ersichtlich ist,
und dann entscheide ich,
welche Spuren ich auswerte.
Oder, äh ... genau.
Welche DNA-Spuren ans IRM kommen.
Was habe ich noch? Schuhabdrücke
habe ich noch gesichert.
Ich habe sie fotografieren lassen.
Nachher habe ich ein Foto erhalten,
vom Fototeam,
welches das fotografiert hat.
Ich schaue, ob ich die Spuren
irgendwie verwerten kann.
* Aus dem Radio
erklingt leise Musik. *
Die gesicherte Schuhspur
gleiche ich mit den Schuhspuren ab,
die in den letzten drei Monaten
gesammelt wurden.
Die werden alle hier abgelegt,
gesammelt und dann verglichen.
So können allenfalls zusammen-
hängende Delikte erkannt werden,
wenn dieselben
Schuhspuren kommen ...
... vorkommen.
Es hilft mir auch, herauszufinden,
welche Marke es ist.
Also was es
für eine Marke sein könnte.
Hier hier habe ich nun nicht
wirklich etwas gefunden, das passt.
Der TV-Zuschauer ist anderes gewohnt:
Menschen sichern Spuren -
und Computer und ihre Datenbanken
erledigen den Rest.
In der Realität
bleibt der Mensch offenbar zentral.
Das Ziel wäre natürlich,
genau den zu finden,
aber es gibt
viele ähnliche Schuhspuren.
Dann kann man es nicht genau sagen,
wenn es zu wenige Merkmale hat.
Auch für den Abgleich
von Fingerabdrücken gilt:
keine ratternden Computer,
sondern denkende Menschen.
Die Maschine, wie man sie vom TV her
kennt, erkennt das gar nicht.
Es ist schön am TV und
ich fände es toll, wenn es so wäre.
Aber es ist Handarbeit, erfordert
Konzentration und Erfahrung.
So.
Meine Minions-Brille.
* Sie lacht. *
Aber nur Gerücht
sind die futuristischen Apparate
und Methoden der Forensiker nicht.
Spezielle Lichter zeigen z.B.,
ob auf einem Beweismittel
Fingerabdrücke
und DNA hinterlassen wurden
und ob sich eine weitere Auswertung
also lohnt.
Wieder ein Verbrechen
im Kanton Zürich.
Karin Bolliger hat Pikett
und wurde aufgeboten.
Es geht es um den Einbruch
in eine Geschäftsliegenschaft.
Geld soll verschwunden sein -
und vielleicht noch mehr.
* Mysteriöse Klänge *
Weil viele Spuren zu erwarten sind,
ist Bolliger
heute mit einem Kollegen unterwegs.
Gummi ist verletzt, das Metall auch.
Ich glaube, das ist der Einbruchort.
* Mysteriöse Musik *
Verbrecher hinterlassen
nicht nur DNA und Fingerabdrücke,
sondern auch
eindeutige Werkzeugspuren.
Auch die können zum Täter führen.
* Mysteriöse Musik *
Man sieht schön die Kratzspuren.
Wenn wir ein entsprechendes Werkzeug
finden würden,
kann man vergleichen, ob es passt.
Wir haben so viel aufgeschrieben ...
Die Stadtpolizei Zürich
ist bereits vor Ort
und bringt die Kriminaltechniker
auf den neusten Stand.
Welche Räumlichkeiten
sind betroffen?
Einfach diverse Büros. Einzelne. Wir
haben sie separat aufgeschrieben.
Zwei Personen.
Sie - und ist der Kollege auch da?
(Mann) Er ist in einer Besprechung.
- Okay.
Dürfte ich kurz Ihre Schuhe ansehen?
- Ja.
Steht der immer so schräg hier
oder ist der verschoben worden?
(Frau) Ich weiss es nicht genau.
- Es wäre interessant zu wissen,
ob sie von der Täterschaft
verschoben wurden.
Ich schaue kurz,
ob ich ihn anrufen kann.
Er ist im Büro? Mhm.
Gut.
(Mann) Seit Montag ist er im Urlaub.
Ich sehe schon einige Spuren
im Staub, oder.
(Mann) Zum öffnen und schliessen
finde ich das eher mühsam.
Ja.
Die Herausforderung
bei den DNA-Spuren ist,
dass sie nicht sichtbar sind.
Man kann nur erahnen,
wo jemand etwas angefasst
und wo die Spuren
gesichert werden können,
die zu einer Person führen, die
an dem Korpus nichts verloren hat.
Er muss dann erklären,
wie die Spur dorthin kommt.
* Quietschen *
Das Interessante ist sicher,
dass man nie weiss, was passiert.
Man kommt am Morgen zur Arbeit
und alles ist noch offen.
Wir haben eine gewisse Abwechslung.
Wir arbeiten draussen und drinnen,
an verschiedenen Tatorten im ganzen
Kanton, mit verschiedenen Kollegen.
Es ist jeden Tag etwas Neues.
* Piepsen der Kamera *
Auffällig ist einfach, dass genau
dieselbe Spur auch im anderen ...
Vor dem anderen Korpus und Tisch
wurde gleich herumgetrampelt.
Also das ist schon speziell.
Ohne Blitz ist es extrem schwer.
Wurde bei Ihnen privat
auch schon eingebrochen?
Nein, bisher Gott sei Dank nicht.
Weder zu Hause,
noch im Auto, noch ... Ja.
Würden Sie denn die Spuren selbst
sichern oder die Kollegen anrufen?
Das habe ich mich
auch schon gefragt.
Ich glaube,
ich würde es selbst machen.
Meine Spuren wären sowieso am Ort.
Ich kenne mein Haus am besten
und weiss am besten, wie ...
... wo fremde Spuren sind, falls
fremde Leute etwas angefasst haben.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
ob das legal ist.
* Dubiose Musik *
Gibt es auch Täter,
die keine Spuren hinterlassen?
Man sagt, jeder hinterlässt Spuren.
Bei jedem Schritt
fallen Hautzellen ab.
Und Hautzellen
sind Träger von DNA-Material.
Unsere Aufgabe ist es dann,
genau diese Spuren zu finden,
die zur Täterschaft führen.
Also hier hat es Einbruchspuren
an diesem Schrank. Da unten.
Ich sehe da genau die Wellenspuren,
wieder von diesen Schuhen.
Wie im anderen Büro auch.
- Sowie auch auf diesem Stuhl.
Ich vermute, dass er
auf diesen Stuhl gestanden ist
und versucht hat,
von oben aufzureissen.
Da ist es viel mehr offen
als hier unten.
Das ist meine Folie,
mit der wir die Schuhspuren sichern.
Der Stuhl ist weiss und es ist
schwierig, ihn zu fotografieren.
Vielleicht habe ich
mit der Folie mehr Glück.
* Dubiose Musik *
Ich dachte, vielleicht ... Gut,
jetzt sind wir darüber getrampelt.
* Dubiose Musik *
Jetzt weiss man, dass die Person,
die hier herumlief,
auch auf dem Stuhl war. Jawohl.
Die Spuren sind gesichert -
es geht zurück ins Büro.
Und dann nach Hause,
in ihre Idylle -
weit weg von all den Tatorten.
Ich bin schon ein wenig
ein Krimi-Typ.
Das wäre sicher interessant.
Ich war selbst nie dabei.
Ich würde gerne
an eine Szene mitgehen.
Das würde ich sofort machen,
mitgehen, ja.
Viel erzähle ich wirklich nicht.
Wenn ich nach Hause komme,
in der Regel ... Nein.
Ich erzähle gar nicht viel
über die Erlebnisse, die ich hatte.
Weil Sie nicht dürfen
oder weil Sie kein Bedürfnis haben?
Ich habe oft gar nicht
das Bedürfnis, ehrlich gesagt.
Es gibt ja auch noch andere Themen.
Würfelchen?
Ja, ja. Wie du willst.
Du fragst immer so viel ...
Ja, weisst du ...
Das kommt in die Suppe?
Ich würde sagen.
- Gut, in die Suppe. - Ja.